Yeah,
I think that researchers themselves
could do a better job of trying to
explain to the public what it is we do.
So first of all,
I would like to say that we need to do
more of this.
Um,
and I think that the public,
if we take the time to do that,
um,
will have different viewpoints.
Of course we're a heterogeneous and
diverse society,
but,
uh,
unless we do more of that,
we can't say that the public has
misperceiving if we don't give them the
information to evaluate.
Um,
I,
I think that,
uh,
there are many elements that we can
explain and speak less than a scientific
jargon.
Um,
uh,
and,
actually work a communication specialist
frankly,
to get messages out in different
languages and different,
uh,
different levels.
You know,
why not let fourth graders here about
what we're doing at the level of fourth
grader university students,
medical students,
medical professionals have different
ways of communicating with the
different,
uh,
constituents in society.
There are many organizations now that,
um,
because the public votes with their,
their,
their checkbook,
in other words,
their taxes on the people they elect.
We have to go to the public,
uh,
and particularly around public private
partnerships,
uh,
that we want to build from the private
sector with,
with a,
a civil society and with the public
sector,
we need to be out and to say,
you know,
what it is,
what our core values are,
what our mission is,
what we can do to be part of the
solution,
not to take on the whole problem.
Uh,
and to build these partnerships with the
public sector.
I am worried that,
uh,
there is mistrust between the public and
academia,
uh,
and uh,
with public entities as well,
but particularly with the pharmaceutical
industry.
Um,
so w we have many corrective actions
that we've taken.
We are trying to respond and get
feedback,
uh,
on,
on what type of activities we need to
improve ourselves on.
But I would like to see us on a much
more positive trajectory where it is
clear that what we are doing is
delivering what the public wants,
the diseases they want us to work on.
And the public has a lot of voices as
well.
So we can't satisfy all.
Um,
all of the needs,
but,
uh,
you know,
certainly we want to be a serving
medical need,
um,
in the way that public a regained some
competence in what we do.
I think that,
uh,
many of the issues that the public has
with Pharma,
we need to listen to and we need to
understand those,
what their issues are and we need to
have an internal dialogue with the,
about these things.
When that happens,
you know,
uh,
we need to negotiate a,
a path out of that.
So I think,
you know,
part of the district trust was around
transparency,
around data and publication,
that data and frankly the safety of our
medicines when we explain what the
safeguards that we do and the fact that
we're a very highly regulated industry
more so than,
than most industries.
And get out with what we're doing that
to show that we've heard what they've
said to us and then what are our plan
are and then to ask them,
is that what you had in mind about our,
our,
our corrective action.
The other thing we can do is just talk
about the great science we do.
Um,
about the lives that are affected by our
medicines and our vaccines,
about the programs that we build,
the disease elimination programs,
the health management programs around
our therapeutics,
because it's not just about the
molecule,
it's not just about the vaccine,
it's about the,
the disease management programs that we
build into this telling the story,
asking our customers are our
constituents,
you know,
how,
how are we doing a getting feedback
changing course.
Um,
and I,
I think that that,
so I,
you know,
I don't look at the public is having a
misperception of us.
Um,
I,
I look at,
uh,
our need to have more of a dialogue with
the public and to evolve science.
It's about evolution anyway.
So a scientist,
we should evolve with the public.
Personally,
I'd like to see progress in infectious
diseases because,
um,
uh,
you know,
we have A.
HIV is still a raging pandemic now.
Uh,
it's not thought about as much in the
developed world because,
uh,
in many Pharma and public private
partnerships working with the NIH and
other public entities,
we now have turned HIV in the developed
world into a chronic disease is very
treatable,
not with the best and not with optimal
medicine.
So we still have room to go,
but the largest part of the,
you know,
the,
the planet with HIV,
uh,
until recently you had no access and now
I'm a,
we were making great strides with the
Global Fund,
pepfar,
um,
other programs that originated out of a
Pharma to get into some of the issues
around access.
So,
but,
you know,
there are two to three,
four,
five,
um,
after HIV.
So Tuberculosis,
malaria,
acute respiratory infections in
children,
etc. Uh,
that,
uh,
really deserve as much attention I think
as hiv.
So I woUldn't want to say one thing,
I would say let's have a grander vision
and tackle the top 10,
at least the top 10.
Tacoma is a,
is a historical disease.
It's,
it's mentioned in the greek papaya ray,
and it's actually mentioned in the bible
and it was in the us,
uh,
in appalachian on indian reservations
after the battle of a denial when,
uh,
basically,
nelson sank the french fleet,
the returning navy and soldiers brought
tacoma to europe.
So this has been a disease in the
developed world,
but with improved sanitation,
uh,
the disease has gone away and actually
on the reservations with some mass
antibiotics.
So until the poverty agenda in the north
south divide is a really,
a solid tacoma is going to be a disease
that requires other modalities including
antibiotic treatment.
Uh,
but agaIn,
I believe that with the current
mobilization that,
that the disease is within reach,
tacoma is caused by a bacteria.
It's usually crowding and in poor
conditions and with repeated infections
of the eyes,
scarring occurs over many years.
That leads to blindness.
Um,
malaria is a mosquito transmitted
disease.
Um,
and uh,
actually again,
uh,
the south all the way up to Washington
and this country was a endemic from
malaria.
Um,
but,
uh,
today 90 percent of malaria and malaria
deaths are in subsaharan africa.
Um,
and,
uh,
again,
the parasites have the advantage because
of their sheer numbers and replication
that they become quickly resistant to
many of the available drugs.
I believe a tacoma tHat,
uh,
the global Illumination of tacoma is,
is within reach by the year 20,
20,
and that is our goals.
I'm going to the world health
organization,
uh,
tomorrow eVening to be part of that
annual meeting.
Um,
that program iS being linked with other
neglected tropIcal disease programs that
again,
uh,
many people in the field have been
working on it.
But for about fifty cents a year,
uh,
with four or five already approved
medicines,
we can look at eight or nine neglected
tropical diseases and imagine and
actually set metrics around elimination
that's different from diseases like
malaria where frankly resistances as
some of the,
the biggest concern.
And we really do need a full pipeline
from early discovery to a full
development to address the continuing
evolution of resistance.
The parasites of the advantage.
Um,
there will always be a need for new
therapeutics until we eliminate malaria.
But I don't see elimination as a,
as a,
as a real viable strategy for malaria
right now.
Very often these are a bacteria,
vIruses,
or parasites that were formerly a
completely susceptible to a therapeutic.
Many people don't.
so one such a bacteria is mrs.
Say,
and people hear about it in the news,
which is methicillin resistant staph
aureus,
when fleming first discovered
penicillin,
penicillin would treat staph aureus that
didn't last very long.
Other agents have been synthesized,
including different penicillins,
completely new classes of agents.
Um,
and I would say now that staph aureus is
pretty well served,
so what I would expect would be there'll
be a lack of a further discovery and
development for staff laureus.
And maybe in a period of time,
five years,
10 years or 15 years,
we'll be back to the problem of not
having agents with staph aureus.
Um,
right now,
uh,
we have gram negative organisms.
So these are bacteria that are found in
water supplies,
especially in hospitals because of the
antibiotic pressure.
There were a,
again,
if you were to get infected with one of
these organisms,
there may not be a therapeutic that will
help any effect against those organisms.
These are the super resistant bugs that
you asked about
in New York city just to make the case
locally in the late eighties,
early nineties,
um,
uh,
there was relaxed control of
tuberculosis and so that patients would
be admitted with tuberculosis hospital
for isolation and therapy,
um,
after two weeks would feel better,
but they need six more months of
therapy.
It will be sent out.
They would often get disorganized
because they were from the inner cities
are actually had a mental illness,
uh,
and this would happen three or four
times until they develop multidrug
resistant tuberculosis.
And in The layman's jargon,
a super resistant bug,
um,
and this was frightening.
Um,
this situation is now playing out in
places like South Africa where they have
something called an xdr,
a tuberculosis.
and so I know I had many patients,
I had many,
and these epidemics,
we'd have outbursts and in clinics and
hospitals.
So I knew health care providers that
were infected and got sick.
Um,
sometimes both the patients and the
healthcare providers were hiv positive
that seemed to promote actually the
aggressiveness of the bacteria
progressing,
um,
in the,
in these patients.
So It was quite a frightening situation.
One of the good things about
international travel now is that people
are more aware of cultures and
environments because they're traveling
on business to,
to emerging markets and frankly,
even some of the less developed
countries,
uh,
so I think they're in general is a,
what globalization has brought as a more
awareness of the,
some of the inequities,
not just with poverty be with diseases.
And uh,
you know,
I,
I hope with some of the economic trouble
in the developed world that we don't
lose sight of the fact that in the
developinG world they are suffering much
worse than we are.
Um,
so that,
uh,
you know,
we have an obligation in the develoPed
world,
uh,
to not lose focus on international
development issues.
In the seventies when a nixon announced
the war on cancer,
um,
budgets were decreased for infectious
diseases.
And this has been well published and
talked about in both the scientific and
the,
in the lay press.
Um,
and look what happened.
Hiv,
multidRug resistant tuberculosis.
I'm a west nile virus.
I think we've responded now what we,
we can't do is relax our,
a surveillance for emerging diseases,
our laboratory capabilities to study
these organisms and then to scale up to
have useful either therapeutics or
vaccines
when sars hit and then people would
probably prefer forgotten about it was,
it was terrifying what,
what happened?
And it was a,
a,
like an influenza type of illness.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
the company I work for actually
synthesize 65 compounds in less than a
year,
uh,
in,
in a very much of a manhattan project
like environment,
um,
to then the disease went away
inexplicably.
Um,
so I think that capability to quickly
respond.
Um,
and also,
you know,
I'm,
I'm a firm believer in science evolving,
um,
in new technologies becoming available.
So when it be nice and actually we are
working on this technology to have a
vaccine response that takes weeks and
not nearly a year and in some cases,
um,
and so there are,
there are approaches and we are working
in that field as well.
Um,
so it's about having existing
capabilities,
uh,
and not relaxed in the guard,
Both on surveillance of new diseases,
but also they built the ability to
respond.